from babe ruth to barry bonds
baseball has another name to add to the
history books rachel balcovich
this week the new york yankees
introduced balkovic as the manager of
their single a squad the tampa tarpons
making her the first woman to hold that
position with a major league affiliated
team i caught up with balcovic in 2020
when she was hired as a hitting coach
for the yankees organization and became
the first woman to don the team's iconic
pinstripes it's a huge point of pride
and actually changes the way that i kind
of feel
throughout my day balkovic had stints in
other mlb organizations but before she
made it into baseball she was told by at
least one team official her gender would
keep her out he was like rachel i'm
really sorry i want to be honest with
you though we can't hire you and it's
because you're a woman and i just was
shocked first of all you know that's
illegal he said well it gets worse and i
was like how could this possibly get
worse he said you know i also called
around to all the other people that i
knew had positions open and they also
said the same thing
that led balkovic to create a
gender-neutral resume including changing
her name to ray the response was
immediate i said hello and he said
uh hey can i speak to ray and i just was
like
i remember my face i was like
i was like this is she
today balkovic says she's hoping her
path to the majors can be an inspiration
to the next generation of young women i
don't think you sign your name on the
dotted line to do something like this
and then say well i don't want to be a
role model i want to be a visible idea
for young women
i want to be a visible idea for dads
that that have daughters you know i want
i want to be out there